well the southwest valley could soon be
getting its first bike park the 17-acre
park will start from warm springs and
stretch to fort apache it provides a
safe trail for riders mary jane belliesa
shares what you can expect
[Music]
a new bike park is coming to a growing
part of the valley local leaders and a
packed crowd filled fest park this
saturday morning to celebrate a kickoff
event for the new park it has a pump
track that's where you can go up and
down it's going to have little bridges
that you can go over
it's going to have some we can bomb down
the hill on and just fun for for kids
and adults to really learn how to do it
safely southwest ridge bmx skills park
would be the first bike park here in the
southwest valley riders i spoke to say
they're excited to have a safe space for
cyclists and for the community ray
rodriguez says there have been too many
deaths involving cyclists on our streets
one of our teammates aaron ray passed
away
due to a negligent driver in a box truck
so i'm excited to be able to stay safe
and off the off the roads and have our
own paved section the new bike park will
start on warm springs and will stretch
up to the dirt hill once construction
begins and while many are here to show
their support for the new bike project
others like butch hampton is worried he
lives in the copper ridge community off
of fort apache and warm springs he says
the county wants to connect to the
neighborhood's utilities which will
impact the main entrance to their homes
are they just going to put up chain link
fences or are they going to have
landscaping that is equivalent to what's
on our side of the street coming in you
know i think it's a good thing for the
kids if it's done tastefully if it's
done inexpensively and impacts our
community i'm definitely not in favor of
it commissioner jones says the city is
working to meet with those living in
nearby neighborhoods to address their
concerns mary gene balliesa live local
now